I was shocked to learn that another
talk-show has stolen one of our show's
most beloved and informative segments is
called tall's tips and it features our
own prop master bill tall there he is
right there
[Applause]
now even worse it was stolen and I'm not
making this up this is all very real it
was stolen by a talk show in France
that's right ladies and gentlemen this
makes it an international incident now I
know there are a lot of talk shows out
there and it's inevitable that sometimes
two shows will present similar ideas it
happened it's happened to us yeah but
why don't you be the judge okay
here's a recent money-saving Tull's
tip from valentine's day that we did
take a look take a glass of apple juice
add some alka-seltzer boom champagne
okay and here's a real clip called les
tutos de Mokhtar translation mocked arse
tips from the French late night show to
spa I'm on post
oh well Duchamp Annie papa
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's ridiculous they stole every
single thing right down to how we staged
it the graphics everything even you and
me laughing too hard at it yes yes
pretending it's funny when that's our
routine I think the part that bothers me
most is the way their guy says BIM
instead of boom now frankly this is an
insult it's an insult to my show ladies
and gentlemen it's an insult to our
country most of all it's an insult to
prop master bill tall okay I Conan
O'Brien am demanding to ship aah I'm on
post ere a formal apology on their show
I would also like French president
Francois Hollande to cooperate with our
government and Interpol to investigate
that talk-show for international
espionage and I would like a statue of
built all placed in Paris's Luxembourg
Gardens with a plaque inscribed built
all France's greatest entertainer
in France if you do not meet all my
demands immediately in accordance with
the rules of the Geneva Convention I
will consider this an act of war USA
[Applause]
good tell are you doing I was hoping
somebody might bring some food out
you